bonjour à tous bienvenue c'est l'heure
de parlement hebdo 45 minutes pour faire
le tour de l'actualité politique et
parlementaire à mes côtés comme chaque
semaine 4 gilbert bonjourbonjour michael
coup d'envoi cette semaine du marathon
budgétaire à l'assemblée nationale un
projet de loi de finances pour 2016
marqué par des recherches d'économies à
réaliser 16 milliards à trouver une
discussion marquée également par
l'amendement très médiatisée d'un ancien
pour une minute françois hollande et
face à la grogne la cgt boycottera aps
la conférence sociale lundi le chef de
l'état est aussi défié par un ouvrier
des chantiers de saint nazaire et par
les policiers qui ont manifesté sous les
fenêtres de la garde des sceaux
le climat est pour le moins tendues et
pour changer d air nous irons voir ce
qui se passe du côté des primaires des
démocrates aux états unis premier débat
hillary clinton a visiblement marqué des
points et pour commenter l'actualité
nous accueillons didier guillaume
bonjour bonjour merci d'être avec nous
est le patron des socialistes au palais
du luxembourg sénateur socialiste de la
drôme alors la demande et c'est la
tradition à vos collègues et à des
collègues sénateurs mais aussi des
députés ce qu'il pensait de vous allez à
bas vous allez voir des portraits au
micro de géraldine bah voyons et france
achèverait écouter bonne équation à la
fois d'être dans le consensus de tous
mais en même temps dans le dialogue en
amont pour permettre d'éviter à la
sortie toute frustration c'est ça pour
moi prison groupe yahoo
c'est un élu après éléments
exceptionnels parce qu'il a une
connaissance du terrain par les mandats
qu'ils occupent dans le même temps c'est
un responsable politique de très haut
niveau
c'est vrai qu'avec le cumul des mandats
les sénateurs étaient peut-être parfois
moins actif ici au sénat c'est vrai que
maintenant moins de sénateurs cumule
donc ça permet un meilleur travail
législatif et on est très présent
au fait des dossiers retraites et au
sénat on a toujours les défauts de ses
qualités
alors que son seul défaut c'est d'être
socialiste a oui et non c'est pas
défaussés sa conviction c'est pas la
mienne mais c'est son problème à lui pas
le mien un gars bien je trouve posée
quel sens de l'autre aussi
quel sens de la formule vous êtes donc
un homme formidable
c'est un exemple vivant sur ton du
nombre non cumul de mandats un exemple
vivant
oui j'ai fait le choix de ne pas me
représenter pour mettre en adéquation
mes convictions avec les avec les actes
je ne pensais pas qu'il fallait être
candidat puis être amené à démissionner
il faut jamais démissionné lorsqu'on a
une mission un mandat on va jusqu'au
bout et donc j'ai fait le choix de me
consacrer exclusivement au sénat et à la
présidence du groupe socialiste
qu'est-ce qui vous disent rémy sénateurs
c'est là qu'en fait vous êtes sur leur
dos quasiment tout le temps non je suis
là beaucoup du lundi au jeudi soir ou
vendredi comme aujourd'hui et je
travaille je travaille pour la cohérence
du groupe de travail pour la cohérence
des dossiers en relation avec l'exécutif
en relation avec le parti politique
auquel j'appartiens
mais je veux faire vivre une gouvernance
moderne
je veux faire vivre le débat dans le
groupe ces listes chacun s'exprime
il n'y a aucune lourdeur chez vous il y
a aucune limite
lorsque l'on arrive à parler à s'écouter
et a tranché les choses vont bien donc
c'est ça le rôle d'un président de
groupe il ne faut pas le surestimer
alors à dérouler un petit peu la semaine
à l'assemblée ça commence lundi avec le
marathon budgétaire
et on ne parle que de lui lui c'est
l'amendement de jean marc ayrault il
préconise une baisse de la cg à la place
de la prime d'activité l'examen du
budget vient de commencer à l'assemblée
nationale 137 députés ont signé au
faveur de cet amendement
reportage dans les couloirs du
palais-bourbon signée jean baptiste
daoulas son amendement déplaît au
gouvernement mais jean marc ayrault est
venu défendre la fusion de la csg et de
l'impôt sur le revenu
ma conviction c'est que le débat
parlementaire s'est pas ont simplement
des députés qui sont là pour entériner à
100 % ce qui était proposé par le
gouvernement mais s'agit pas non plus de
défaire tout ce qu'a fait le
gouvernement donc la proposition que je
fais avec terra la muette une
proposition qui s'inscrit dans le cadre
du budget du gouvernement
mais pour le patron des députés ps oui
au débat mais non un amendement qui
brouilleraient la politique fiscale du
gouvernement les députés socialistes
peuvent encore faire évoluer le budget
mais uniquement sur quelques sujets bien
précis
je pense en particulier au soutien aux
collectivités locales à la question dont
nous ciblons aujourd'hui les aides à
l'investissement l'investissement public
l'investissement pour les pme il reste
peut-être encore oui quelques éléments
de discussion possible
les inflexions fiscal réclamée par le
parti socialiste depuis le mois de
juillet ne seront donc pas pris en
compte par le gouvernement
l'ailé gauche du parti dénonce un
verrouillage des débats il ya des forces
verrouillage disons le ils ont le
clairement au sein du gouvernement
c'est vrai mais aussi ici et ceux qui
aujourd'hui ils verrouillent
l'expression des socialistes qui
entravent l'esprit de réforme de justice
fiscale porteront une forte
responsabilité dans les difficultés de
la gauche dans les mois qui viennent y
compris à l'occasion des élections
régionales des députés frondeurs déjà
prêts à imputer au gouvernement une
défaite aux régionales même si
paradoxalement la proche des élections
les conduit à exprimer leurs critiques
un peu moins fort que les années
précédentes
didier aumont un petit peu de mal à
comprendre 137 député c'est pas rien on
signé l'amendement de jean marc ayrault
maire de nantes en bruno le roux dans le
reportage le dire s'est amoindrie
passera jamais qu'est ce qui se passe
mais le budget de la france ce n'est pas
un amendement futile signé par l'ancien
premier ministre
ancien président de groupe le budget de
la france sont des orientations
c'est une baisse de la dette une baisse
de la fiscalité une baisse des déficits
et une amélioration du pouvoir d'achat
pour les français ça on le comprend
c'est ça le message qu'ils ont peut
prêter plus de 37 c'est pas une majorité
puis le débat va avoir lieu
et puis ce n'est pas dans la première
partie je veux pas rentrer dans la
technique la partie recettes c'est la
partie dépenses il faut mesurer les
conséquences de cela ce qu'elle
souhaitait faire le chef de l'état et
les deux premiers ministres successifs
c'est d'arriver à faire une grande
réforme fiscale une grande réforme
fiscale c'est pas le grand soir
et de là les réformes en 100 jours les
réformes de la fiscalité de notre pays
depuis 2012 sont les plus importants
donc la baisse de la suit depuis honnête
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi j'ai
écrit j'ai contribué à écrire dans le
projet socialiste dans le programme de
françois hollande que j'étais favorable
à la fusion de l'impôt sur le revenu et
de la csg
et je vais vous expliquer pourquoi je ne
pense pas qu'il faille le faire
maintenant ce serait une erreur fiscales
et ce serait une erreur politique parce
que ce genre de grandes réformes
ça se fait en début du quinquennat en
période de croissance
parce que réformés fusionner l'impôt sur
le revenu et la csg
je vais essayer de pas être trop
technique 5
sans compter que ce n'est peut-être pas
constitutionnel puisque l'impôt sur le
revenu est un impôt par tranches
alors que la csg est un impôt
proportionnel il faudrait les fusionner
ça voudrait dire que des gens paieraient
plus est compte tenu que le président de
la république a annoncé qu'il n'y aurait
pas d'augmentation d'impôts alors ça ne
peut pas se mettre en contact en france
ce serait envoyer un message
contradictoire c'est la raison pour
laquelle je ne pense pas qu'il faille le
faire maintenant
mais cette réflexion doit demeurer sur
la table oui au débat non prévu
d'amarrer n'ont pour le moment tels que
ça pourrait être mise en place mais la
question que pose jean marc ayrault qui
est une question très importante c'est
qu'est ce qui se passe lorsqu'on change
de situation lorsqu'on a la paix la
prime pour la prime pour l'activité
et puis
est ce que ça donnerait c'était la csg
moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui les
orientations fiscales du gouvernement
vont dans le bon sens redistribution
n'allant pas plus loin mais ouvrons le
débat parce que si nous devions faire
cela ça demande un chamboulement complet
qu'est-ce que très politique à force de
dire aussi de la part de manuel valls
que tout ce qui avait été fait avant ça
c'était pas terrible
il fallait s'attendre siège que jean
marc ayrault fasse une tentative manuel
valls ne dit rien absolument rien et
jean marc ayrault a depuis longtemps
annonce qu'il est pour cette cette
mesure mais je pense qu'il ya eu des
discussions et les choses avanceront
mais écoutez ce n'est pas grave quand
pas de débat pas grave c'est le débat si
le débat entre le débat il est sur la
table ce n'est pas un vol à ajouter à la
cacophonie quand j'entre sur ce sujet
oui mais la cacophonie qui la donnent
les gens présentant dès que vous vous
interrogez le chef de des minoritaires
de la fronde socialiste est minoritaire
en exil lui mais bien sûr qu'ils
existent mais ils sont minoritaires
il ya eu un congrès ils ont été battus
et une large majorité a choisi une
orientation politique
c'est comme lorsque l'on vote dans les
groupes parlementaires mais ils disent
mais c'est verrouillé mais moi je leur
dis que par leurs interventions
on risque de prendre une dérouillée aux
élections régionales le problème c'est
pas que ce soit verrouillé c'est pas
verrouillé le débat c'est de leur faute
mais non mais faut qu'ils arrêtent de
passer leur temps de critiquer et de
critiquer sans cesse la politique du
gouvernement
message bien aux socialistes message
bien compris on passe à mardi l'exécutif
intervient dans le dossier air france en
visite sur les chantiers de saint
nazaire le président de la république
s'est exprimé sur les violences
survenues la semaine dernière après le
comité central d'entreprise d'air france
des propos qui ont immédiatement fait
polémique je vous propose de leur écoute
et oui le dialogue a repris parce qu'il
ya un moment où chacun prend conscience
que la violence peut être destructrice
qui vaut pour air france vous pour le
pays si nous voulons éviter des
confrontations les violences des
divisions les stigmatisations il faut
dialoguer en début de semaine la semaine
dernière manuel valls a dit une chose
françois hollande semblant dire une
autre oublié l'ailé les voyons entre
guillemets qui ont lynché les lé patron
d'air france si votre est la prêtresse
votre interprétation ce n'est pas la
mienne ils disent la même chose
les violences qui ont eu lieu air france
la semaine dernière sont inacceptables
intolérables c'est des violences
physiques des cadres en temps failli
être lynché mais on oublie trop les
vigiles on oublie trop les gens quitter
l'aek qui se sont fait aussi molesté
ils ont porté plainte la justice doit
faire doit doit suivre son cours et
lorsque il y a des attitudes comme celle
là qu'elle vienne de syndicalistes ou
d'autres
c'est intolérable mais en même temps le
gouvernement et pour le dialogue et air
france
il est hors de question de parler du
plan b de 2000 et quelques suppressions
de postes avant de parler du plan a
remis une semaine en soutien
les patrons d'air france dans le plan
social cette sono à l'arrêt enfin n'ont
qu'a dit non ce qu'a dit manuel soutenir
le gouverneur gouvernement soutient la
direction d'air france lorsque la
direction d'air france est malmené comme
ça a été physiquement et ça ça sera
toujours notre position par contre les
plans social marine non il n'y a pas de
plan social nous nous voulons un
dialogue
nous voulons discuter mais il ne faut
pas que les pilotes prennent en otage
l'ensemble du personnel d'air france
donc l'appel qu'a fait le premier
ministre hier au sénat lors des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
était excellent et très équilibré jamais
nous ne tolérerons les exactions
physique mais jamais nous tolérons la
casse sociale
c'est aussi simple que ça dans le choix
des mots c'est important et voyou de la
part manuel valls charlie de la part de
nicolas sarkozy
vous situez ou non mais je pense que
c'est pas le problème des mots la
chienlit ça veut dire autre chose
la chienlit ça se réfère à ce qu'est
venu le général de gaulle à propos de
1968 quand la france est dans la rue le
choix des moins d'importance manifesté
le choix des mots est très important on
l'a vu avec morano avec d'autres est ici
avec masson le sénateur on envie
religion qui a écrit par l'esl a donc le
choix des mots est important mais moi je
met pas sur le même plan chienlit
parce qu'avec les connotations qui vient
derrière ce que ça veut dire le mot
voyou et le mot voyou qui a prononcé le
premier ministre avait conscience comme
que dans l'opinion ce mot était mal
interprété aussi de la part de manuel
valls
ce mot a été mal interprété mal compris
parce que nous sommes à un moment où la
france est fracturée plein de division
plein d'opposition où il ya certaines
catégories de français qui souffrent des
ouvriers des salariés des chômeurs mais
en même temps moi je veux vous dire très
franchement est fortement
ma conviction c'est que l'ordre
républicain doit régner dans ce pays
qu'en aucun cas il faut qu'il n'y ait de
débordement même possible vers l'avant
nous conduisent à la dérive reste mardi
c'est le traditionnel rapport de la cour
des comptes qui a lieu chaque année les
magistrats de la rue cambon s'inquiètent
très fortement des conséquences de la
baisse des dotations de l'état aux
collectivités locales
cette dernière estime que la baisse des
investissements locaux qui en découlent
et évidemment alarmante alors dit
guillaume la cour des comptes fait une
préconisation
elle propose que 2 les fonctionnaires
qui partent à la retraite ne soit pas
remplacé
vous avez été président de département
est ce que vous seriez vous auriez été
en mesure d'appliquer cette réforme
proposée par la cour des comptes non
mais les préconisations de la cour des
comptes sont parfois ambivalente parfois
contradictoires c'est elle dit d'un côté
dans ses précédents rapports que les
collectivités locales dépense trop puis
là elle dit que les collectivités
locales n investissent pas assez je
crois qu'il faut être entre les deux
quel est le bon diagnostic alors pour
vous elles se trompent diagnostic là
quand elle dit ça aujourd'hui oui je
pense je pense je pense parce que c'est
lié à ce qu'elle préconise donc la
position que nous avons nous la majorité
nationale aux côtés du gouvernement
c'est de faire en sorte que réduisant
les dettes les déficits etc
il faut que chacun apprenne sa part et
les collectivités locales doivent s'y
prendre leur part dans la mesure où le
budget de fonctionnement des
collectivités locales a beaucoup comment
augmenter ces dernières années mais s'il
a augmenté c'est parce que l'état fait
beaucoup de transferts il n'a pas
augmenté par la bonne volonté des maires
des présidents d'intercos de
départements ou de régions des
transferts de l'état non compensés en
plomber les collectivités locales
c'est la raison pour laquelle il faut
retrouver une fiscalité juste pour les
collectivités locales investissements et
des dotations juste alors après au
niveau de l'investissement
moi je vais vous dire franchement ce que
je pense certaines collectivités locales
peu nombreuses sont vraiment en
situation très difficile n'arrive même
pas per et certaines vazquez gens mal
géré et très peu d'autres parce qu'elles
ont des chez beaucoup de charges mais la
plupart elles n'investissent pas par
consignes politiques parce qu'elles ne
veulent pas que le gouvernement
réussisse
qu'est ce que c'est au moment où le
chômage vont accuser la droite par
exemple c'est ça oui je dis que la
droite ne prend pas ses responsabilités
républicaines dans ce cas là qu'elle le
fait exprès de qu'est ce que ça veut
dire profiter des baisses de dotations
pour accuser sans cesse l'état pour le
clouer au pilori pour dire pas du tout
regardé je peux pas investir dans le
logement social
elles n'investissent pas dans le
logement social parce qu'ils ne veulent
pas de logement social parce qu'elles ne
veulent pas d'immigrés parce qu'elles ne
veulent pas de livre dans leur commune
d'assat oui elles ne veulent pas dire
en dehors des et de pauvres dans leur
commune et donc elles n'investissent pas
et après elle dit c'est de la faute au
gouvernement
moi je pense qu'il faut une position
équilibrée l'encore le gouvernement à
baisser ses dotations mais des annonces
ont été faites
le milliard d'euros annoncé par le
président de la république pour
l'investissement 500 millions pour les
villes 500 millions pour les zones
rurales va dans le bon sens alors la
situation est dure mais moi ce que je
veux vous dire ici
ces haltes à la schizophrénie halte à la
schizophrénie intellectuelle halte à la
schizophrénie politicienne on peut pas
d'un côté vouloir baisser toutes les
dépenses on va voir le budget du sénat
peut-être en parlerons nous la droite
dit il faut baisser de 150 milliards
mais alors 150 milliards ou comme en
hiver où ses doigts de sérieux alors
dans ce contexte didier guillaume ya
aussi un débat qui relance et celui sur
la réserve parlementaire
cette somme d'argent qui permet aux
parlementaires d'aider les communes de
financer certains projets locaux elle a
été réformé il ya quelques mois les un
sénateur du doubs veut tout simplement
sa suppression explications de jérôme
rabier opaques favorisant le conflit
d'intérêts inutile ou trop coûteuses
pour l'état
les critiques pleuvent sur la dotation
d'action parlementaire souvent surnommé
réserve parlementaire
pourtant depuis sa création en 1959 pour
l'assemblée nationale puis son
utilisation par les sénateurs à partir
de 1988
la pratique est de plus en plus
transparents et encadrée alors que la
répartition était auparavant très
inégale en fonction des postes occupés
et de l'ancienneté des parlementaires
cette pratique est désormais révolu
chaque sénateur peut attribuer en
moyenne 160 mille euros soit un budget
de 56 millions d'euros pour la haute
assemblée la loi sur la transparence de
la vie publique votez après laffaire
cahuzac a aussi imposé la publication
des attributions ainsi chaque citoyen
peut désormais savoir à quels projets ou
à quelle association de l'argent a été
versé
mais pour certains élus cela ne suffit
pas bruno retailleau souhaite ainsi la
répartir en fonction de l'assiduité des
parlementaires de son groupe
d'autres veulent la consacrer uniquement
à l'aide aux collectivités et 10
sénateurs viennent de déposer une
proposition de loi pour la supprimer
cette fameuse réserve parlementaire n'a
décidément pas fini de faire parler
d'elle
chacun y va de sa proposition sur cette
réserve parlementaire vous vous dites
quoi vous dites que en période de baisse
des dotations aux collectivités locales
il faut surtout pas y toucher
absolument c'est un mythe cette cette
dotation parlementaire ce qu'on appelait
la réserve ça a fait parler au coach
avait des grosses enveloppes dote pas
mais mais ça s'est fait en toute
transparence et nous avons travaillé
avec le président bayle dans le
précédent mandat
et maintenant pour mettre la plus grande
transparence c'était la réserve avant
non ce n'était pas le cas avant et vous
certains n'étaient même pas au courant
qu'il pouvait avoir de la réserve
parlementaire et d'hôtels quoi rager
d'essonne des sommes alors vous
astronomique voir je vais vous dire
d'abord interdiction totale de verser
des réserves de la réserve parlementaire
des associations ce n'est pas possible
la réserve parlementaire doit être
réservée à l'investissement des communes
n'étant pas les loups l'instant dont on
parle et qui ont des difficultés et
communes auraient le droit d'utiliser
cet argent comme il le souhaite et non
c'est sur des projets d'investissement
je veux faire bien sûr les associations
cette addiction aux associations exemple
je veux faire une station d'épuration je
fais la traverse d'un village
je construis un logement il me manque un
peu d'argent le sénateur le député mais
de la réserve parlementaire 50100 mis
d'accord notamment pour les plus petites
communes moi j'ai de la tribu qu'aux
petites communes les grandes communes
n'ont pas besoin donc à lézat c'est
aujourd'hui je pense que supprimer la
réserve parlementaire
en période de difficultés de financement
pour les collectivités locales serait
une erreur et en même temps je pense que
la réserve parlementaire c'est de
l'ancien temps donc moi je fais une
proposition je suis pour la suppression
de l'attribution de la réserve
parlementaire par les députés ou des
sénateurs et que l'argent qui est
aujourd'hui attribué pour la réserve
parlementaire soit distribué par
départements aux préfets dans de cale
dans le cadre de ce qu'on appelle la
detr la dotation d'équipement des
territoires ruraux afin de la renforcer
et qu'il ait plus d'argent venant de
l'état pour les territoires dans mon
département la drôme
le montant de la réserve parlementaire
attribué par les sept parlementaires
c'est un peu moins environ 20% de la
detr vous rendez compte propositions je
vais les faire président du sénat oui je
propose je proposerai au président du
sénat opposants de l'assemblée nationale
au parlement je ne peux pas enlever la
réserve parlementaire ça serait un signe
donné aux communes qui sont difficiles
de dire ben voilà il nous retire encore
des aides exclusivement pour de
l'investissement des communes des
collectivités locales et je propose qu
elles ne soient plus attribués par
parlementaire à la tête du client est
attribuée par le préfet dans le cadre de
la commission départementale pour les
grands dossiers d'investissement voilà
pour cette proposition on ne travaille
pas évidemment sur nos antennes on reste
au sénat qui a examiné et voté le projet
de loi des droits des étrangers
on vote solennel un texte très largement
durci par la majorité de droite gianni
faire c'est mettre un vote solennel pour
un texte durcit de bout en bout
il signe d'abord la fin du titre de
séjour pluriannuel et impose des quotas
par catégorie de migrants
la majorité sénatoriale a également
refondu les conditions d'accès des
étrangers au soin
l'aide médicale d'état est ainsi
remplacé par une aide médicale nouvelles
limites et à la prévention et à
l'urgence les conditions de regroupement
familial sont également resserré pour la
droite
ces mesures visent à limiter
l'immigration clandestine
c'est un texte qui porte en lui une
politique migratoire clair et surtout je
voudrais insister sur ce point le fait
qu'il faut lutter très fortement sur
l'immigration régulier irrégulière qui
est vraiment le problème pour nous à
gauche ces mesures sont jugées trop
restrictive et alors qu'on avait un
texte équilibré avec d'un côté
l'intégration des étrangers qui sont en
france de manière régulière et de
l'autre la lutte contre l'immigration
clandestine
là on a un texte qui fait de l'affichage
politique et qui n'a qu'un seul objectif
c'est d'essayer de ramener des voix qui
vont à l'extrême droite
une commission mixte paritaire devra
désormais trouver une version commune
entre les deux textes sortie de
l'assemblée et du sénat
en cas d'échec l'assemblée aura le
dernier mot
texte voté au sénat mais alors dans les
discussions s'étaient compliquées dans
l'hémicycle parce que vous êtes même
affrontés avec un sénateur jean louis
masson qui a déclenché les tollé à
droite comme à gauche notamment sur des
propos assez difficile à entendre
vous êtes d'accord oui ce débat sur les
droits des étrangers des très importants
il ya eu d'un côté ceux qui soutenaient
le gouvernement pour essayer de
de ne pas être naïf en même temps de
considérer que ce sont des êtres humains
et de l'autre côté la droite sénatoriale
sarko un sénateur
non mais la droite c'est elle qui a
durci beaucoup de textes mais quand on
entend monsieur masson sénateur du doubs
du nan nan nan sénateur de la moselle et
vosges de la moselle dire l'immigration
d'aujourd'hui c'est le terrorisme de
demain ou quelque chose comme ça c'est
ignoble
c'est inacceptable c'est pour ça que
j'ai fait un rappel règlement et que le
2 août le déontologue du sénat comme le
bureau du sénat doit statuer je demande
au président larcher qui statue sur
cette phrase pour des 5,6 est ce que ça
veut dire vous les avez cinq six trous
de choses foulée des sanctions ne peut
pas laisser passer ça lorsqu'on est
sénateur de la république
on ne peut pas aller contre la
république est bafoué le pacte
républicain
mercredi didier guillaume les policiers
manifestent sous les fenêtres du
christiane taubira ils étaient des
milliers à manifester place vendôme est
devant les tribunaux de région à
l'origine du mouvement une fusillade à
saint thois après la permission d'un
détenu fiesch vs au cours de laquelle un
policier de la bac a été grièvement
blessée manuel valls a tenté de rassurer
les policiers pauline dame paris lille
strasbourg ou encore bordeaux
cet après-midi ils étaient des milliers
rassemblés jusque sous les fenêtres du
ministère de la justice pour manifester
leur ras-le-bol
lorsqu'on demande d'où s'échappe le
manque l'arsenal juridique bas soit
adaptée de plus en plus adapté aux
missions de la police
et qu'on arrête de cet angélisme
qui consiste à penser que tout le monde
est beau et tout le monde est gentil une
profession en colère après la fusillade
qui a eu lieu en seine-saint-denis
durant laquelle un policier a été
grièvement blessé par un détenu en
cavale
alors pour éviter le divorce entre
police et justice
manuel valls est venu apporter des
réponses à ce malaise
il ya des dysfonctionnements il faut les
corriger
nous entendons donc la colère des
policiers
le premier ministre propose de durcir
les peines pour le trafic d'armes
lourdes ou encore restreindre les
permissions de sortie des détenus sont
nécessité avérée
françois hollande devrait recevoir les
syndicats de la police et de la justice
la semaine prochaine des policiers qui
se mettent en grève comme sa place
vendôme
le gouvernement a de quoi être inquiet
et en même temps il a répondu il a
répondu lula profil de bombardements a
répondu parce que je comprends
l'inquiétude des policiers je les vois
dans mon département
je comprends quand ils prennent un jeune
ou moins jeune une fois deux fois trois
fois quatre fois cinq fois ce 10 mai la
colère est bien sûr un stade terrible et
en même temps en même temps la justice
fait son travail donc allés manifester
sous les fenêtres de christiane taubira
ce n'était pas le bon endroit pour
manifester par rapport à cette loi faut
aller manifester sous les fenêtres de
monsieur sarkozy n'est bruit parce que
ce sont les lois sarkozy qui se sont
appliqués là c'est celle de 2004 et la
personne n'y a personne qui a été la
personne qui a été relâchée qu'a commise
ce drame atroce sur un policier j'aurai
une pensée pour sa famille ses enfants
en vertu des lois sarkozy mais je ne
sais pas la réponse que je vais vous
faire on peut pas s'en contenter
moi je demande que l'on change la loi
parce que faire des actes administratifs
les notaires peuvent aller en prison
on n'est pas obligé de faire sortir un
trouvent les chômeurs n'est pas que
j'aie de faire sortir un délinquant pour
aller faire un acte administratif
comment est ce que vous voulez changer
je viens de vous le dire la personne
sort pour aller signer un acte
administratif chez le notaire etc
non ils sont pas c'est l'administration
qui vient de faire signer à l'intérieur
si ce sont des conditions durcies semant
des conditions non pour souder score
certains noms mais si on veut être
sérieux et réintégrer les gens il faut
qu'ils puissent aussi c'est ça toujours
et ça a toujours existé mais pas de faux
débat mais il faut durcir les choses et
il faut dire aux policiers que nous
sommes derrière eux
et aux magistrats de bien regarder leurs
actes et vous le dire dans les titres
c'est climat social qui est de plus ou
moins il est très tendue la cgt
boycottera la prochaine conférence
sociale qui aura lieu lundi prochain
un signe de plus dans la dégradation du
climat social à deux mois des élections
régionales
l'elysée est confronté à de multiples
tensions avec les syndicats ou avec
julie buil à la crise air france et la
chemise déchirée d'un de ses cadres ont
elles marqué un tournant pour le
gouvernement
dix jours après cet événement qui a fait
le tour du monde
la colère ne semble pas retomber en
visite hier sur le site du chantier stx
à saint nazaire
françois hollande s'est retrouvé face à
un représentant de la cgt qui a refusé
de lui serrer la main
a lyon c'est emmanuel macron qui a vécu
une journée tout aussi mouvementé
accueilli par des huées
puis par un jet de yaourt lancé en
direction de son pupitre des événements
qui interpelle les politiques
ce qui me choque aujourd'hui c'est qu'à
chaque fois qu il n'ya plus au fond cet
esprit de respect cette éthique du
respect dans la république
et ça je pense que nous en sommes tous
responsables il faut vraiment tirer la
sonnette d'alarmé sur le sujet si
françois hollande continue à plaider
pour un dialogue social apaisé la colère
s'enracine dans un climat de plus en
plus explosif un sentiment d'inquiétude
justifié pour certains le font de la
sphère le fond de l'exaspération c'est
que on ne voit aucune solution possible
françois hollande n'est pas dans cette
situation de pouvoir rassembler fédérer
et entraîner un pays ni sur le plan
social n'est sur le plan économique ni
sur d'autres points alors que sa main
tendue ne trouvent plus preneur l'elysée
peut-il s'attendre au pire lundi
prochain débutera la quatrième
conférence sociale avant de réagir des
dégâts je vous présente gym jarrassé
notre partenaire du figaro le scan qui
sera avec d'autres à nostang nickel pour
les questions demeurent tendues mais
juste avoir un petit commentaire sur ce
qu'on vient de voir
elle est quand même loin la france a
peur est 2012 voulue par le candidat
françois hollande
oui mais c'est l'objectif du président
françois hollande que la france soit
apaisée en autant il ya des noms tension
tensions sociales tensions sociétales
tensions internationales fin la france
est un pays en guerre et des réfugiés
qui sont en europe qui crée ce climat et
à ce moment là
françois hollande est l'homme de la
situation parce qu'ils continuent à
apaiser
alors on regarde ce syndicaliste que
prévoit la symbolique oui c'était
peut-être un militant d'un parti
d'extrême gauche je n'en sais rien je
veux pas rentrer dans ce débat c'est
parce que c'est un geste symbolique mais
c'est une personne mais le pendant tout
le voyage
il a serré la main à tous les autres et
moi je regrette mais c'est leur choix de
plus que la cgt n'est pas la conférence
sociale
c'est dommage la politique de la chaise
vide n'est jamais une bonne tant pis
pour eux tant pis pour le pays
tant pis pour le pays pour eux c'est pas
la question moi j'ai pas dire tant pis
pour eux ou pas pour eux ils prennent
leurs responsabilités elle est
respectable mais tant pis pour le pays
je te le dialogue social doit on a
l'impression qu'il a été un peu cassé
quand même avec cette affaire de
violence de la france qui ont fait le
tour du monde partout à l'étranger c'est
vraiment le symbole de l'échec le madame
légale à auxerre la violence la violence
d'air france c'est pas le gouvernement
n'y est pour rien
sa discussion entre du personnel d'air
france et la direction d'air france les
image détestable en fait le tour du
monde nous en avons parlé
enfin repentance atteindra pas prévu est
5e à françois hollande et à manuel valls
à ces places là chez difficile c'est
pour ça qu'il faut rassembler rassembler
encore et il faut dialoguer il faut
dialoguer sans cesse même quand c'est
compliqué et je sais que le dialogue
avec la cgt continue aussi en coulisses
même s'ils ne seront pas à la table de
la confiance que vous nous dites c'est
qu'ils ne sont pas la conférence mais
qu'on discute avec eux dans les
coulisses je suppose que les discussions
ont lieu parce que c'est un partenaire
important
incontournable et vous attendez quoi tu
pars incontournable c'est un partenaire
important comme les autres il n'y a pas
de partenaire incontournable
vous attendez quoi vous rendez vous de
cette conférence sociale j'attends à ce
qu'on débouche sur l'avenir du pays
on ne regarde pas dans le rétroviseur on
a en a un certain nombre de problèmes de
flexibilité problème de travail problème
d'annualisation nous allons le compte
personnalisé d'activités qui va être
essentiel pour le le droit des salariés
les retraites complémentaires enfin tout
ça ça mérite que le paritarisme continue
à jouer alors vous savez que jim jara c
est là où avec nous sur ce plateau vient
tout de suite à la loupe du scan
d'idiomes l'actualité du jour c'est le
référendum du pea sur l'unité de la
gauche aux régionales qui a débuté ce
matin à 8 heures ces derniers jours le
psa il monte les téléphones cdas de ses
adhérents avec des sms et des messages
enregistrés de jean christophe
cambadélis pour les inciter à aller
voter
il ya une crainte d'une faible
participation à ce référendum qui n'ont
pas été inondées ils ont reçu un appel
compte tenu que ça a été envoyé à 5000
exemplaires on peut dire ça ça inondé
cent mille personnes qu'on voit ça fait
chaque militant reçu un exemplaire c'est
les moyens modernes de communication en
leur disant chère amie va voter
évidemment ils l'ont fait moi j'ai voté
ce matin vous allez voter déjà voté ce
matin oui si on a espéré consultant sur
sur ma tablette dans la lah rien de 100
millions 800 mille quatre cent mille
cinq cent mille 5000 peu importe
enfin portland peu importe le nombre de
votants mais bien sûr sans même se
réalise pour vous peut importe le nombre
de votants c'est pas le sujet c est ce
que nous sommes capable d'enclencher un
mouvement pour dire oui à l'unité dans
des régions où depuis dix ans voire plus
nous travaillons dans les exécutifs avec
des vice-présidents écolo des vice
présidents communistes des
vice-présidents radicaux que moi entre
la vaillance mais non ces deux cas
surtout il n'y a pas une délibération
qui n'est pas voté mais quelle sames par
ces majorités les vice présidents tous
les moyens il propose des réponses au
cours des jeux vous le dire parce qu'ils
confondent les raisons nationales et les
raisons régionales et je le regrette
nous allons faire de la politique
nationale dans ces régionales est ce que
ce n'est pas faire porter la
responsabilité aux autres partis de
gauche d'une défaite dont le ps n'aurait
également être responsable ans et faire
porter la responsabilité aux autres
partis de gauche de leur incurie à faire
la différence entre la politique
nationale la politique régionale
ils sont responsables de leurs décisions
et ils sont responsables camps dans le
nord de bastia les responsables de la
défense n'ont pas du tout pas du tout
les défaites de la gaule alréenne au lac
ans je viens de vous dire non
la défaite de la gauche sera défaite des
candidats de gauche moi je ne dis pas
ils seront responsables de la défaite
je pense qu'ils sont responsables de la
situation d'aujourd'hui en mélangeant
nationales et régionales et notamment
moi j'ai voulu dire dans une région où
l'extrême droite est aux portes de la
gouverner de dire cela n'est ce n'est
pas grave
d'entendre le parti de gauche de jean
luc mélenchon de dire toute façon ne
votera pas pour la gauche pour les
socialistes deuxième tour voilà c'est
fait on ne fait pas la différence entre
marine le pen et la gauche
autre sujet de l'autre actualité du jour
c'est la déclaration de candidature de
jean yves le drian en bretagne alors le
ministre de la défense est très apprécié
à la fois par les militaires et par
françois hollande et par l'exécutif
qu'est ce qui va se passer en cas de
victoire est ce que vous souhaitez qui
restent mises de la défense d'abord il
faut être heureux qu'un ministre est
apprécié par la gauche et par la droite
c'est très rare s'est très bien oui mais
c'est rare mais c'est très important
il est très apprécié c'est un très bon
ministre il fait le choix de s'engager
en bretagne parce qu'il est très
apprécié aussi en bretagne par la droite
et par la gauche et par les gens de la
bretagne
donc il a fait la conférence de presse
ce matin
les choses sont claires il n'y a aucun
problème j'entendais le président des
républicains à l'assemblée d'hier on
peut pas être ministre et candidat enfin
il se rappelle pas que alain juppé était
lui même maire de bordeaux est premier
ministre
ce sera le choc après la finale de ce
soir joie de jean yves le drian de jean
yves le drian
il fera le choix le 13 décembre au soir
entre sa région et le ministère mais
comme il l'a très bien dit ce matin dans
sa conférence de presse évidemment il
n'y aura pas de passe-droit il est
remplaçable n'y aura pas de passe-droit
ce ne sera pas le choix de françois
hollande bien ce jeu je suppose qu'ils
en parleront ya en tout cas sur ce sujet
une jurisprudence qui est celle de
françois rebsamen que vous connaissez
bien puisque vous lui avez sextuplé à la
tête du groupe ps au sénat
alors il a dû quitter justement le
gouvernement pour rejoindre ça mérite du
jeu on a l'impression qu'il a assez mal
vécu cet épisode dans un livre des
journalistes henri vernet et renaud dély
qui sort cette semaine qui consacrait à
la violence en politique
françois res r'n'b françois hollande n'a
pas d'affect ce type est un galet et
vous les voyez comme ça aussi
non ça hollande je ferai en françois
hollande est quelqu'un qui est dur parce
qu'il faut être dur lorsqu'on est
président de la république il faut pas
tremblé à chaque à chaque prise de
décision ou se mettre aux abris dans ce
qu'on se fait attaquer petit a lâché 7
il faut changer de métier n'a jamais
caché ses proches françois hollande et
d'une dureté incroyable est
indispensable pour gérer le pays mais il
n'est pas dur avec ses relations la
phrase que vous cite françois rebsamen
elle aurait été prononcée d'après ce que
m'a dit l'intéressé il ya quatre ans
donc on parle pas de là près du
quinquennat tandis qu'au final françois
hollande n'est pas un président seul
aujourd'hui françois hollande est un
président qui a des difficultés en
termes de cote de popularité est un
président qui restera dans l'histoire
parce que malgré les difficultés de
laura réformé il aura et formés dans le
sens de la justice sociale
il aura fait des réformes qui touchent
le plus grand nombre et non seulement il
n'est pas seul mais moi qui étais type
de soutien
non mais moi qui était avec lui
lorsqu'il était à 3% aujourd'hui les 25
ou 26 % ça fait plaisir de démarrer
cette hauteur là donc on a réussi
il a réussi à être élu président de la
république pendant 2 3 %
je ne doute pas qu'il réussira à voir un
tel outil à se faire réélire réside en
la portant de 25
vous êtes l'un des rares à avoir un tel
optimisme vis-à-vis de françois hollande
parce que moi j'ai une dernière
politique oui parce que moi je ne
cherche pas à faire des petites phrases
avoir des dépêches afp ou à passer sur
les plateaux dont quelques uns ont des
choses à caen quand on dit les choses
qui vont bien ben voilà c'est comme ça
vous vivre mieux et je vise personne je
dis il vaut mieux dire du mal pour se
faire entendre
moi je dit du bien j'ai eu si j'ai des
choses à dire je les dis à l'intéressé
jeudi au président de la république mais
je pense vraiment que la politique menée
par le président de la république uppr
et milices va dans le bon sens elle est
dur à expliquer il faut aller sur le
terrain et que tout le monde se consacre
à aller sur le terrain et lyon devait
toujours de faire des bons goûts qui
sera réélu en 2010 est selon j'espère
qu'il le sera mais dieu merci merci jean
et en france en duo avec le jeudi et le
dossier du diesel qui refait surface en
plein débat pendant leur budget
pressés notamment par la ministre de
l'écologie de députés ont entériné le
rapprochement entre les prix du gazole
et de l'essence 1 centimes de plus par
litre pour le diesel le nouveau
dispositif devrait entrer en vigueur en
éléments d'explication avec rim benameur
après plusieurs années de débats le
gouvernement décide de s'attaquer au
diesel une hausse de la taxation sur le
gasoil plus un centime d'euro par litre
en 2016 puis en 2017
dans le même temps la taxe sur l'essence
bénéficiera d'une baisse de même ampleur
j'ai annoncé hier décisions importantes
vous l'avez rappelé kelly convergence
essence diesel attendu depuis très
longtemps qu'ils n'avaient jamais été
mises en oeuvre
pourquoi parce que tout simplement on
considère et vous en parlait souvent à
cette antenne que le disais les français
sont préoccupés pose un problème sur la
qualité de l'eau oui mais les
socialistes se défendent de créer un
nouvel impôt
cela va donner des recettes
supplémentaires puisqu'il y a un gros
parc diesel dans notre pays ces recettes
supplémentaires ne seront pas un
prélèvement supplémentaire pour les
français elle seront reversés et
notamment pour baisser la fiscalité des
personnes âgées
l'opposition soutient cette sortie
progressive du diesel mais dénonce la
méthode choisie
il faut aujourd'hui qu'on aille vers la
fin du diesel à loger charmant mais pas
en taxant les pauvres automobilistes 200
artisans les pauvres commerçants à qui
on a dit achetez du diesel ce sera moins
cher
les parents leur ont les matraquant avec
une tag aujourd'hui elle les écologistes
qui ont fait de ce combat leurs
priorités se félicite temps fait en tout
cas une belle victoire pour les
écologistes nous le demandons depuis
1996 au moment de vote sur la loi sur
l'air et cette décision et surtout
l'engagement d'autres faire cela pendant
cinq ans donc de rattraper le prix du
diesel sur celui de l'essence c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour la santé des
français
aujourd'hui plus d'une voiture sur deux
fonctionne au diesel pour aller encore
plus loin une mission parlementaire a
été confiée à delphine batho elle sera
mise en place dès la semaine prochaine
alors cette hypothèse d'augmentation de
prix désiré été exclu il ya quelques
mois elle revient aujourd'hui est ce que
c'est vraiment le bon moment la bonne
méthode
oui c'est la bonne méthode plus un
centime pour le diesel - un centime pour
le prix de l'essence l équilibre c'est
un signe qu'il faut c'est l'équilibré à
papa fallait le faire maintenant
nab a maintenant rue après est ce qu'il
ya un temps pour faire les choses
nous sommes en période budgétaire nous
faisant part de budgétaire on nous dit
faut le faire avant c'est n'importe quoi
après quand j'entends madame pécresse
dire on matraque en matraque les
automobilistes c'est arrive elle importe
mais elle elle veut matraquer tous les
dizaines de milliers de franciliens
en supprimant le pass navigo qui tue
d'amancey terrible alors un peu deux ans
dans le cadre des matraquages elle s'y
connaît
non c'est pas un impôt supplémentaire
aujourd'hui un problème du climat et un
problème de deux particuliers un
problème du rejet et il faut absolument
faire des efforts et il faudrait pas
leur a évidemment c'est pas le centime
c'est pas le un centime et c'est un
signe il faut que l'industrie automobile
française fasse sa mue elle ne l'a pas
fait donc allons-y moi je ne veux pas
montrer du doigt moi j'ai une voiture
diesel ne pas montrer du doigt tous les
gens que je connais autour de moi en
zone rurale dans la drôme qui ont des
voitures 10 el sadate aller parce qu'ils
n'ont pas les moyens d'avoir des
voitures à essence pour l'instant donc
voila mais il faut aller dans cette
direction
le un centime centimes c'est de l'
équilibre ça permettra d'améliorer et de
baisser aussi les impôts pour les veuves
qui ont qui sont entrés dans l'impôt sur
la taxe d'habitation et le foncier que
ça c'est très important mais il faut que
l'industrie automobile face à mu elle va
changer un petit peu d'air on va aller
du côté des états unis 4 et on va aller
jusqu'à las vegas et jusqu'à las vegas
on a eu lieu le premier débat démocrate
que vous êtes un casino dans les casinos
dans un hôtel casino exactement de ne
pas alors il y avait cinq candidats et
une grande favorite
et c'est donc hillary clinton qui a pris
l'avantagé à l'issue de ce premier tour
de piste deux moments forts entre
l'ancienne première dame et son
principal concurrent démocrates sur la
question des armes à feu et le sujet
polémique des e-mails privé d'hillary
regarder ces extraits high tech je pense
que nous devons regarder la réalité en
face
nous perdons 80 personnes chaque jour
désormais il est temps que le pays aussi
face à saluer le sénateur zone 2 à voter
5 francs contre le projet de loi brédy
service des 4 ans et plus de 2 millions
d'achats illégaux ont été votés
robin tunney la réalité c'est que les
américains sont fatigués d'entendre
parler de vos satané email moi aussi moi
aussi la classe moyenne de ce pays
s'effondre 27% américains vivent au
seuil de pauvreté dans le nord est ce
qu'il ya une leçon politique à retenir
si vous deviez en retire une de ce grand
show des primaires à l'américaine
vous savez nous nous avons fait des
primaires à plusieurs reprises des
socialistes mais lorsque ce sont les
américains pile de pont alors là c'est
autre chose c'est dans un casino et le
bruit en audition du dans un casino nous
ça ce casino de biarritz ou ailleurs ça
aurait été ça aurait été mal pennant ils
ont l'habitude des grands shows bon ils
font leur show américain c'est
typiquement américain voilà il arrive là
parler et larry clinton une femme de
gauche
oui mais on peut pas comparer la
politique américaine un pontique
française ou européenne
mais effectivement aujourd'hui je
préférais lalique unique une tonne à
donald trump soho est ce que je veux
dire on imagine votre positionnement
dernière question la rouquette un petit
peu le côté des états unis je reviens
petit peu en france en tout cas à
l'amoureux du sport que vous êtes un
amoureux du ballon ovale pronostic pour
ce week-end face aux all blacks moi je
soutiens mon ami philippe saint-andré
qui est de kate chez moi je pense que
les français savent se dépasser en les a
déjà battus en leurs amis une tôle à
cardiff la dernière fois et moi je pense
que la france peut créer un exploit ça
va plus loin parce que c'est la question
est-ce que tout est possible tout est
beau c'est moi je mise pour la victoire
de l'équipe de france absolument c'est
avec cette petite touche qu'on va
terminer cette émission merci beaucoup
didier guy merci à vous merci à tous on
se retrouve
la semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle
émission de parler vos rideaux bonne
semaine à tous bonne 24